first of all I had some wonderful
teachers mentors in elementary school I
had a woman by name in mrs. Picard who
taught me how to read and loved to read
and so I've been a reader ever since
then and in high school I also had some
wonderful mentors a government teacher I
nameable Cal an who taught me how to
fight box he and I serve as governor
lieutenant governor together we're an
independently but we certainly worked as
a team mr. Walker was panic people were
very good to me and one of the things
I've tried to do in public life is to
try to make it so that harry reid's of
the future can succeed a America is a
wonderful country and I tell young
people that I visit with that if i can
make it anyone can and that's what i
want to want to be able to explain to
people and i try to do in this book no
excuses we can all make it the only
thing I work toward is trying to have it
so that there are fewer hoops to jump
through I the guy to jump through some
hoops that maybe we shouldn't have to
jump through but I don't want to save
poor me but things are a little better
than they used to be you know even from
searchlight they have buses that take
kids to school in Boulder City I didn't
have that luxury I i want to go to high
school i figure out a way to get there
myself and much of the time I hitchhiked
back and forth health care was really
awful in those days it's not great now
but at least you can go to the doctor
when you're sick we couldn't do that
education is better searchlight doesn't
have one teacher teaching all eight
grades we still have many kids going to
school there but we have a team of
teachers and so things are better than
they used to be but they're not as good
as they should be
Oh